[Music]
do we need vaccine mandates
[Music]
these protesters in new york say it's
their right to decide what goes into
their body
and mandates for state employees and
healthcare workers go too far
but in europe italy has gone even
further from october 15 anyone wanting
to participate in public life will have
to be vaccinated or have recovered from
a coveted infection
the penalty will be a hefty fine
[Music]
many are now asking whether these new
rules are part of a trend that will lead
to a global vaccine mandate
it could be the only way to beat the
covert pandemic
hi i'm ben fazoulen the number of
coronavirus cases continues to rise in
greece and now that schools have resumed
following the summer break the
government's introduced tougher
legislation aimed at persuading more
people to get vaccinated
it's lunchtime at this fish restaurant
near athens
everyone who works here is vaccinated
the owner checked their vaccination
certificates
having all eight of his employees
inoculated is the only way his
establishment could qualify his covet
free and operate without restrictions
there was one employee who didn't want
to get vaccinated at first but when it
essentially became mandatory he did it
was the only way to keep his job
at first the new rules only applied to
workers in bars and restaurants
but now everyone has to inform employers
of their status
unvaccinated people have to be tested at
least once a week at their own expense
employers who do not enforce the rules
can be fined up to 1500 euros most
support this policy
it protects us all
i think that it's crucial for the common
good i'm a teacher
how can i enter a class without being
vaccinated you just can't do that
the rules in the health care sector are
especially strict
those who refuse to get vaccinated have
been put on unpaid leave
that has triggered protests and left
many hospitals with a real problem
40 of our 1600 employees have been
suspended
unfortunately that has a real impact
because we have serious staff shortages
and that's true for almost all the
hospitals in the country
at the biggest vaccination center in
athens things are quiet
only around 56 percent of greeks are
fully vaccinated and infection rates
remain high
the government says it might have to get
tougher still to boost the vaccination
rate
we first have to evaluate the data and
then see where mandatory vaccination may
be beneficial for other professional
groups where gentle persuasion hasn't
worked greece is opting for a tougher
line with ever stricter rules and
penalties
arthur kaplan is director of the
division of medical ethics at the nyu
grossman school of medicine so should
the covert vaccine be mandatory in your
opinion
i think it should we've tried to educate
people to choose the vaccination we've
tried to incentivize them in many
countries including the us with rewards
free meals drinks
lotteries that they could win
but we still have a hardcore population
here in the us and around the world
that's not vaccinating and the only way
out
of continuing to live under the shadow
of covid is to boost those vaccination
rates i think mandates will do it
is it ethical to force someone to get it
by law
i think it's very ethical people say
it's my choice it's my body i should be
able to choose but in a pandemic the
principle is don't kill your neighbor
don't harm vulnerable people who have
immune diseases or children who can't
yet be vaccinated that's got to be the
dominant ethical principle that leads
directly to the justification of
mandates
looking at the u.s what's the point of a
mandate for teachers in many cases but
in most cases not for the students when
you're talking about harming your
neighbor
right well in the u.s we don't yet have
approval to vaccinate under 12. so the
teachers want to be protected from
literally the students who might bring
covid into the classroom
the u.s hasn't been aggressive enough in
my view in testing so that we can't
assume that people will home test and
then not send their children to school
so it's very important to protect
teachers janitors school personnel when
the kids can't be vaccinated so that's
the rationale
and what about health care workers a lot
of hospitals are losing much needed
staff because of these new new rules
well look it is a danger that people may
still hold out and say as a hospital
assistant a nurse i'm not going to work
if you make me vaccinate i actually
think the numbers are not bearing that
out we've had mandates in a number of
health systems where i am in connecticut
nearby in new york we've lost a very few
people despite all the noise and
rhetoric they haven't quit they don't
want to become unemployed they don't
want to lose their pension and if we
push a universal mandate through in
health care there's nowhere else to go
to work so i i think that the staff
shortages
maybe could be a small problem but look
you don't want your nurse or your
nurse's aid to harm you or your loved
one if they're in the healthcare setting
i think you got to stick with the
vaccine
of course not but
is it really such a small problem when
we see that so much of this skepticism
is among health professionals
well it's a problem when health
professionals don't follow the science
it's a problem when they're not good
role models
sadly many of them are subjected to
misinformation
sadly some of them are also worried
about issues like fertility which is not
an issue for the vaccines so
you know you can't let fear and
misinformation drive health care
uh policy the other issue is you know
there's burnout in a different way if we
don't vaccinate them and our hospitals
get overwhelmed the nurses the doctors
burn out they get tired that leads to
staff shortages too and if they get
covered that leads to staff shortages so
it's not sort of vaccinate and risk
losing people i think it's more accurate
to say vaccinate and perhaps some people
will quit but you're not going to lose
people because they get sick arthur can
you tell us what the research actually
says about how well vaccine mandates
work
i've done a lot of research myself in a
different vaccine for the flu we push
that through the united states as a
requirement for health care workers
at my own school before we mandated flu
shots we had a vaccination rate about 77
percent in a very big health system
today it's 99.4 percent mandates will
work employees get used to the idea that
they have to vaccinate as a condition of
employment i think the protests will
calm down once we institute the mandates
in health care settings
so is the mandate our only chance to get
out of this pandemic
well look vaccination is key but i think
we've got to do a couple of other things
you do want to test
more testing home testing making sure
you know
some countries are testing once a week
for the unvaccinated that's not enough
testing is a crucial tool and that ought
to be pushed more and hopefully we'll
find some medicines that might act as
preventative many drug companies are
working on those so if we had that one
two kind of combination vaccination plus
preventative medication then i think
that's the road out
arthur kaplan great to have you on the
show today pleasure talking to you
thank you
a brief look at a couple covert stories
making news picking up on our topic
today of vaccine mandates
new york hospitals have begun firing or
suspending health care workers for
defying a state order to get the covert
19 vaccine that's led to staff shortages
forcing some hospitals to delay elective
surgery and reduce services
lobbyists say the measures won't only
hurt patients but also affect hospital
revenues
and japanese prime minister yoshihida
suga says his country is lifting a
coronavirus state of emergency in all
regions
the order's been in place for nearly
half a year daily cases fell from 25 000
last month to just over a thousand on
monday japan plans a gradual reopening
so some restrictions will remain in
place
and lastly let me hand you over to our
science correspondent derek williams
with one of your questions on the
coronavirus
is vaccine immune response all about the
levels of antibodies they induce or are
there other factors to consider
an antibody
is a roughly y-shaped protein produced
by the body that's able to recognize and
dock on to the outer surface of an
invading pathogen like a virus by
docking on
the antibodies might neutralize it
directly by by blocking the mechanisms
that allow it to to invade a cell or
they might flag up the invader for
destruction by other layers of the
immune system's defenses
it takes some time for the immune system
to learn how to tailor
specific antibodies to to specific
pathogens so
the levels of those particular
antibodies are often used as a kind of
rule of thumb
when it comes to judging immune status
if someone has a lot of the antibodies
specific to sars cov2
then that's viewed as a sign that the
person is unlikely to get a severe case
of of covet 19. but it's a lot more
complicated than that because in
particular what are called b cells and t
cells also play
vital roles in protection both during an
infection and in immunity down the road
antibody levels will tend to drop off in
the months after infection or
vaccination experts say because your
body doesn't keep churning out
antibodies to every disease you've ever
been exposed to
at high levels forever that would be
a waste of resources instead
immune system cells store long-term
information on known pathogens
and how to make antibodies against them
if you're exposed then again later they
recognize the invader and they can
quickly ramp back up antibody production
and immune defenses
um in talking about immune response or
or a lack of it however
we tend to focus on antibody levels
because
they're a fairly straightforward metric
to measure
but they're really just one factor in in
a very complex system
[Music]
nice to have you along stay safe and see
you again soon bye-bye
[Music]
you